[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
thank you
so the very last thing the coronation
needs is a sickening garnish of the cup
price Kardashians Harry is not deserving
of my Empress your opinion did a lot of
damage that day you did a lot of damage
and I had to come along and fix it just
like Harry did a lot of damage and other
people had to come along and fix it you
Louis Walsh you want to defend the
indefensible come on mate it's all over
isn't it from Madonna it's embarrassing
she's iconic she's one of our biggest
pop stars ever you just don't like her
[Music]
well good evening Fernando welcome to
praise Morgan on censor King Charles
will be crowned in May in a ceremony
gilded by British history Millions if
not billions will watch around the world
as Charles formerly ascends the Throne
of westerns to Abby where every
coronation for the last 957 years has
been staged think about that for a
moment a millennium of History our
history Britain's history 30 kings and
queens are buried there it's the sacred
place where the late Queen herself was
married and crowned and where she marked
the death of her own husband and that
ribbon of history is what makes the
British Monarchy unique State occasions
that the coronation belong not just to
the Royals but to the people of Britain
and the Commonwealth the very last thing
the coronation needs is a sickening
garnish of the cup price Kardashians
hogging the spotlight and making notes
for the next cash grabbing expose Harry
won't say yet if he'll attend but he's
made his terms very clear
I don't know whether they'll be
you know watching this or not but what
they have to say to me and what I have
to say to them
will be in private and I hope it can
stay that way
the irony is just breathtaking isn't it
416 pages and countless interviews
spewing intimate family secrets now he
wants privacy and according to his
latest whining interview he also wants
the Royals the people he's just been
slaughtering for weeks on end to say
sorry
what I'd really like he says is some
accountability and an apology to my wife
he told the telegraph you know what you
did
oh this is beyond parody you know what
you did and I now know why you did it
and you've been caught out so just come
clean he's addressing this to our King
and to our future king and he went on it
was a hundred and pages and now it's
down to 400 Pages it could have been two
books put it that way and the hard bit
was taking things out
he then accused the media of having a
quote bleep ton of dirt about my family
I know they have it and they sweep it
under the carpet for juicy stories about
somebody else hmm
you've got a big story on Sunday in
which your sources at the palace were
basically indicating that
notwithstanding the onslaught that's
come their way King Charles in
particular was prepared to consider
reconciliation before the coronation in
may now I've got to say before I get you
to talk about that my own sources
tonight who I would describe as pretty
impeccable
um believe that's a bit of a reach say
that Charles is absolutely livid and
actually reconciliation right now is
most definitely not on the cards there's
been no contact whatsoever with anyone
in Montecito and that may well stay the
same so let's let's thrash out our
sources here how confident are you that
you think that Charles really does want
to reconcile with somebody who's really
shown that any attempt to do anything
just immediately gets commercialized
well good evening peers I think um
sources aside if you speak to people who
really know the king they will tell you
that he absolutely does not want to be
estranged from his son for the rest of
his life there is no doubt that Charles
has lived the whole royal family have
really livid about what um Harry has
done but we have a few months now very
very crucial months um leading up to the
coronation and actually one of the most
extraordinary lines in that book was
Harry's Revelation that Charles said to
him and William after Phillip's funeral
these boys don't make the rest of my
life a misery which at the moment
um Harry is doing a very good job of but
what Charles will not want really great
one is estrangement from his son forever
and any kind of major overshadowing of
the coronation and if there is nothing
done no contact at all between now and
the coronation I really do think we're
going to keep peering from Harry and
Megan in a very negative way and and
Charles will want to avoid that but you
know what my response would be it's like
all right keep yapping if you want to
you've done your worst on honestly keep
yapping and just completely ignore them
don't invite them to any Royal events I
mean Jenny Bond why the hell should they
be invited to a coronation it's the
people's coronation it's our coronation
for our Monarch all they've done these
two is damage the monarchy damage the
reputation of that institution damage
their family the royal family on which
the monarchy's future depends what on
Earth have they done to deserve an
invitation to a coronation well it's not
just Charles by the way it's Camilla as
well getting crowned who Harry just
trashed in his book
yeah but I think you know this is the
most important day probably in the whole
of Charles's life and if as the loving
father which I believe him to be he
wants his younger son to be there then I
think that is his right and his
privilege and I think an invitation will
be extended to them I I think to not
invite them really is going to be uh
feeding the hand that bites Charles so
it'd be wise to invite them and uh if
they do come uh I think it we the media
actually should take it upon ourselves
not to make it not to make it overshadow
the coronation I mean we don't want to
have screaming headlines about them so I
think we should just have a footnote at
the bottom of our coverage of the
coronation and say also in attendance
were the Duke and Duchess of Sussex I
think that might be one approach
you'll be bringing Tesla Dunlop
um you are the great apologist for the
Megan and Harry here's my question for
you why would two people who hates
everything the Royals seem to stand for
hate the monarchy are intent on
destroying it have done nothing but
trash it and diminish it in the last two
years why on Earth would they want to be
at a coronation of the next monarch of
this country pears I thought you'd read
the full 400 pages of spare and you will
have got the message loud and clear
there is no macro Harry plan he is a
died in the wool royalist no he doesn't
yes I'm afraid he's going about it all
the wrong way he's done unspeakable
damage but he wants to save the money no
no no I'm being serious
Tessa let me just respond to that what
he wants is to keep the titles the Royal
titles for him and his wife because it's
the titles that make the money and
they're making hundreds of millions of
dollars his book number one Global
bestseller his documentary series huge
success blah blah blah of course it is
he's trashing the royal family from the
inside it is a boy in pain
I'm so sorry please I'm so sorry who
grew up in a goldfish is he in pain or
has he ever been happy which one is it
he's telling us how happy he is he grew
up in a goldfish Bowl who's thrashing
his way out of the Gilded cage but
actually as well as he doesn't know how
to exist without the Gilded oh no he
does I incidentally I'm no apologist for
Harry but I do apologize on your behalf
because one minute you set their peers
and you say oh they'll keep yapping away
they should be ignored there is no way
if they so much has thought that you
would ignore what they say you stoke the
boiler
let me be clear people say Mr me and go
why do you keep banging on about me why
do you because they keep trashing the
Royals in podcasts in books in
documentary Series in interviews it
never stops and I say to them now I will
stop writing and commenting about them
if they just shut up go to Camp
Montecito so be the happy people you
keep telling us that you are stop
trashing the royal family stop attacking
our monarchy stop diminishing this
country if you do that I'll leave you
alone
the dignified Jenny Bond reduce it to a
footnote please but you couldn't resist
doing that because like them you make
money
I bow to nobody of course I do everybody
who's involved in covering the rules
that's my case makes fun well you're
making money appearing on this show
tonight double time yeah exactly so
you're making money too out of it so
let's not be Hypocrites Jenny Bond look
no I'm bouncing nobody in my admiration
of Jenny Bond but she would have been
the first in her previous capacities the
BBC's Royal doin to probably not
actually reduce them to a footnote the
coronation because you know it's a big
hot story and this is the problem I'm
ridiculous isn't it is that is it
unfortunately everywhere they go so does
the lens of attention because they make
it their job to make sure that we don't
leave them alone that is exactly why I
think they should not be at the
coronation for this reason I ask myself
a very straightforward question which
will be the bigger circus if they don't
come or if they do come and if they come
they're likely to be booed we all know
that there'll be a lot of attention on
them because they're there well that'll
be the story they get booed at the
coronation exactly whereas if they're in
Montecito I agree we're all free to
concentrate on the coronation so I feel
very strongly they shouldn't come I also
hang on you had a long go I also feel
equally strongly that the Royals should
not be proposing a negotiation meeting
because we've heard Harry's terms he
wants an abject surrender I wouldn't
trust him as far as the point
um this is the problem I would have if I
were Charles and William in particular
is how do you trust them how do you
trust them given that almost all their
private conversations with Harry have
now appeared in this book including
really intimate stuff including a prince
Phillips Funeral and so on how on Earth
can they trust him to have some sort of
private meeting which stays private
well that's a great question and that's
something that's even been acknowledged
by sources close to Harry and Megan he
said to me and I've written that that
even they acknowledge that there's an
issue there that perhaps the royal
family might not trust that private
stays private but what I would say is as
much as it might stick in the core of
many many members the royal family
particularly the ones you've just
mentioned who come on to heavy fire in
the book I think if the king isn't seen
to somehow do something I think he's
going to come onto even more heavy fire
from his son and other people down the
line but but that will be the great test
I think if they if they do propose some
sort of I'm not saying a negotiation but
some sort of sit down and then something
leaks out and it comes from Harry and
Megan's side then I think it probably is
game over but at least the king may have
tried yeah I mean Jenny Bond it is a I
feel incredibly sorry for for Charles
he's lost both his parents in the space
of two years he's probably still
mourning his mother who just died a few
months ago he's taken on the monarchy
you know he's our new monarch he's about
to be crowned the king of this great
country three I mean all these huge
pressures both personally and
professionally and then he's got his his
young son causing just total endless
Relentless Mayhem I mean if that was one
of my sons I've said to them I've got
three boys in the 20s one of you does
this to me and goes Rogue like this
that's it Bang there won't be any
reconciliation parties you're done
well you see I don't think he wants to
lose his son as well as having lost his
parents and I do think that Charles is
quite a compassionate guy and I think he
would probably agree with me that what
we're witnessing here is almost the
unraveling of a youngish man who um is
so mentally fragile now and so confused
there's so many errors in the book
um and conflicted within himself and
really suffering and like I agree I said
some terrible things
I want to pick you up on that thing
about the mental health thing I don't
see somebody suffering or in pain I see
a smug little narcissist making a ton of
cash abusing and revealing secrets about
his family I don't see anyone fragile
whatsoever you know he on the one hand
he says I'm the happiest I've ever been
on the other hand he wants us to believe
he's a pain struck young guy he's not
he's really faulty you know he's had a
long time to get over the pain that by
the way millions of people have to go
through losing parents when they're
young it's not not
live to him his own brother went through
exactly the same thing and doesn't seem
to feel the need to trash his family in
public so I just don't really Buy in
Jenny to this you know he's racked with
pain and is so fragile I think he
doesn't give a damn about the damage to
the mental health of all his relatives
and yet he's supposed to be the prince
of Mental Health
I think he is racked with pain and in
his book I thought it was very very
moving when he said that when for you
for a second lot of therapy he was
frightened of losing the pain he had
felt for all those years for the loss of
his mother he was frightened of losing
that pain in the therapy because he
would lose his mother again and I
thought it was incredibly moving now I'm
not going to defend Harry for all he's
done all he said a lot of it's
abominable most of it's loopy and I
agree I think he's he's a little bit
unbalanced and deluded perhaps because
all the drugs he took I don't know
his mental health I think he's a I think
he's a California all the time when
you're out there Tessa Dunlop you've
been raging away as normal you know what
have I said this wrong you are renowned
for lacking empathy I won't use I've got
plenty of memories
I actually have a lot of empathy for the
right people actually and my entire
career
empathy no no I so empathy for the
people who deserve it Harry is not
deserving
who has watched Harry from birth through
the death of his mother you don't have a
shred of empathy for his peculiar
lifestyle that's trained him for nothing
that's left him with job loads of
expectations
I went to a state school and actually
what he should have done is go to a
state school and you'll grimacing yeah
I'm absolutely just just calm down the
pair of you uh I've got a perfectly calm
neither of you signed it at the moment
now can I just Rich coming from you
you're normally the one blowing up but
go on I've actually sat here trying to
get a word no choice for a long time
but I mean let me make this point the
coronation is not just a personal
occasion now you can understand the
father wants to involve his son in all
sorts of things and it's but it's not a
royal wedding it's a coronation it's an
occasion of State
and you've got to ask yourselves what is
the most dignified way that we can have
this because it is an occasion of state
and therefore there must be a great deal
of dignity that won't be by having Harry
Potter I totally agree
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
uh well Harry and Megan uh sorry to keep
banging on about them but I keep banging
on about everybody else don't they so we
have no choice until they get exhausted
and we all get exhausted and we can all
move on but for now they remain in the
position that they are demanding an
apology from the royal family for all
the filth that they've thrown at the
royal family in the last two years
but why should the royal family
apologize when you consider what's
happened with Jeremy Clarkson now
Clarkson wrote what he has admitted was
a stupid and inflammatory newspaper
column that overstepped the mark the
outrage was predictable and it was
frankly Justified as he now concedes but
he apologized on Twitter said he got it
completely wrong then on Christmas day
he wrote directly to Prince Harry on
Christmas day think about that and
yesterday he issued a sprawling same
face self-immolation of a public apology
about as groveling as it could be I
really am sorry he pleaded all the way
from the balls of my feet to the
follicles of my head this is me putting
my hands up into Mia culpa with belzon
it doesn't get more fulsome frankly than
what he posted on Instagram and coming
from Clarkson he would probably rather
shoot himself and be like that normally
it carried even more weight
but it wasn't enough
for Harry and Megan
and he took me back actually to when I
was asked to apologize to Meghan Markle
for doubting her word on Good Morning
Britain and one of the reasons I refused
was why would I apologize a for
something I believe I.E she lies and
secondly if I did Apologize what do you
think would happen
anyway even if I pretended that I was
sorry they wouldn't accept it she
wouldn't accept it she'd just use that
as an excuse to go even harder that's
what they do they're the victims always
perennial victims
so I refuse and I left and I'm very
happy about that because I wouldn't be
here doing my show if I hadn't done that
but Clarkson is now in a similar
position looking like he may possibly
lose a lucrative and highly popular
series of shows on Amazon Prime perhaps
even Who Wants To Be A Millionaire at
ITV and you might have your own view
either way about whether Clarkson should
be canceled in this way I don't think it
he should be I don't think that
punishment fits the crime of a stupid
joke in a column
but let's go back again to the apology
they were desperate for an apology from
Clarkson simply so they could reject it
they could have accepted it noted it
even ignored it but instead they reveled
in it pouring fuel on the Flames of his
humiliation without as they lashed him
in a statement for writing articles that
spread hate rhetoric dangerous
conspiracy theories a misogyny it's
clear this is not an isolated incident
shared and haste they said but rather a
series of Articles shared in hate got
the dripping pomposity of that statement
and the disingenuousness of it
Harry let us remind ourselves it's just
literally just published a best-selling
416 page book which is effectively a
series of Articles shared in hate and
when it comes to misogyny he like his
wife identifies Arch feminists and yet
here he is and we've gone to the audio
book to put it in his own words
describing the disabled matron that he
mocked at school
unlike the other matrons Pat wasn't hot
Pat was called Pat was small walking was
hard stairs were torture she descend
backwards glacially
often we stand on the landing below her
doing antique dances making faces
do I need to say which boy did this with
the most enthusiasm we went on mocking
her as she came down the stairs the
reward was worth the risk
for me the reward wasn't tormenting poor
Pat but making my mates laugh
where's Pat's apology
and what about the first woman he slept
with
I suspected he was referring to my
recent loss of virginity in glorious
episode with an older woman she liked
horses quite a lot and treated me not
unlike a young stallion quick ride after
which she'd smack my rump and sent me
off to graze among the many things about
it that were wrong it happened in a
grassy field behind a busy Pub
lovely way to talk about this older
woman a private citizen who's now the
subject of global mockery
who is that woman does he care about the
way he talked about her
it's not exactly chivalrous is it to
reveal stuff like that in a book that's
been read by millions around the world
but it's her apology
and how about the female newspaper
editor the Harry really didn't like
who the hell is this editor loathsome
toad I gathered
everyone who knew her was in full
agreement that she was an infected
posture on the ass of humanity plus an
excuse for a journalist an infected
pustule on the ass of humanity what does
that say with
being nice to women
being supportive of women being a
feminist
where's the apology for that female
newspaper editor
is it going to be one for that blatant
misogyny and what about Camilla the
queen console his own stepmother she was
the villain
she was the third person in the marriage
she needed to rehabilitate her image in
a funny way I even wanted Camilla to be
happy maybe she'd be less dangerous if
she was happy
his own stepmother the love of his
father's life our Queen to be she'll be
coronated too
a dangerous villain
where's Camilla's apology
for that hateful rhetoric
it's in my point here
if anyone should be groveling for
forgiveness and issuing apologies isn't
it Harry and Megan
for selling all the family secrets to
the highest bidders
Trisha here's my central problem with
this and you and I have disagreed about
a lot of this this whole story from
start to finish in fact you're on the
Good Morning Britain episode that led to
me departing but on the central charge I
make of rank hypocrisy when you hear
those excerpts from Harry's book in his
own words particularly I would argue the
way he mocks this poor matron and we
don't know what's happened to her that
is blatant misogyny the way he talks
about her in that book
who is he to really be demanding
apologies for misogyny from others
without offering one himself to those
that he's been misogynist towards
I think as Harry rightfully said in
Camilla's words and Camilla you know the
uh Queen consort has been very strong on
this it was more the violence uh that
that Jeremy Clarkson involved in that
you know Game of Thrones clumsy Game of
Thrones quote-unquote joke and I think
it was more the violence that they were
talking about
misogyny I don't know if it is if you
put something into context about all the
boys mocking somebody who was disabled
which I I don't agree with at all but
it's the actual violence of putting it
out there and the way in which it was
done uh without enaming the person
actually naming the person and the
person already having said that
um they've suffered as a result of
hatred in the Press they've had death
threats and so on so first of all I was
thinking that and I don't think we
should lose the site that it's not the
sussexes
um perhaps putting Jeremy Clarkson out
of a job that's got nothing to do with
whether he apologizes or not you and I
appears no and Richard Tice would know
as well for our employers we sign a
contract that we won't bring our
companies in to disrepute now if our
companies if our employers decide that
we've actually done that then you know
it's up to them whether they fire us or
not okay but on the on the on the fact
that they have simply refused to accept
what is clearly a very long and fulsome
apology this is what everyone have been
demanding well actually it is if you
read the whole thing you post on
Instagram yeah no I did absolutely I did
well you don't think I'm comfortable
with it no I I wasn't it did seem a
little bit you know from the balls of my
feet and what have you it did and I
don't understand peace maybe you you
know better than I obviously when it
said private and confidential how do we
know the contents you know I I just
don't get it it did seem the fact that
it was so publicly done
um but surely the way of do to do it
would have been to quietly go about it
and what have you but we are talking
about sorry we are talking about an
apology made to the two least private
people in the world right now people who
knows
every private conversation of their but
if they're relative to say that well
well two wrongs don't make a right but I
I just found were they right to refuse
politics
we can all choose to what we want to do
with it well were they right
did he sit well with me I I yeah we live
in this cancel cultural world where
everyone screamed and Jeremy Clarkson
must never be allowed to you know walk
again in public or get a job I said that
but but who said that I I believe it if
you do repent if you do admit what you
did was completely wrong particularly if
it's a dumb joke in a newspaper column
right which it was it was a stupid thing
you shouldn't have done it no one's
defending what he wrote right so let's
just agree on that but if you then make
a wholesome public apology which goes
against everything Clarkson stands for
by the way
for the people who then receive it to
literally not just refuse to accept it
but go on the attack seems to me utterly
graceless
I don't think that for me personally I
don't think they were on the attacker I
thought they were stating the obvious
about you know but
um I I will have to disagree about the
fulsome apology you might see it as that
maybe you're a mate of his uh from the
reading well I mean look I'm not to be
honest let me clarify that as I said on
last night's show I have a scar on my
head from where he punched me in the
head so we're not exactly buddies I do
get on I have to be friends I get on
okay with him now in the sense of you
know a bit like uh you know two I guess
two porcupines prowling around each
other when we meet at parties I don't
know whether you've heard this Trisha
this is what Iman said about you along
with another uh guest I had uh last week
she said this
I watched you yesterday and the day
before I watched you be gaslit by two
ignorant black women I actually felt
quite sorry for you so I want to say
welcome to the club Piers Morgan how
does it feel to be gaslit when claiming
something is racism how's it feel it's
annoying right it's annoying this was of
course about our quite fiery debate in
which I got very exercised about the
fact that Megan and Harry for two years
led the world to believe that the palace
had been racist about the skin color of
their baby and then they decided to turn
around and say actually we never meant
that at all which I thought was
deplorable you defended it and that was
iman's verdict on your defense I was
basically getting gas lit what's your
response
um not so much the gas lit bit but um I
guess Iman and I would have to
um agree to disagree I wouldn't call
anybody ignorant just because they don't
agree with my point of view
um and I don't think it's helpful
especially when we're discussing
something like racism
um and you know one black person calling
another person black ignorant because
they don't agree that so that that I
find that I find sad I I'm saddened by
that and and you know so I'm not going
to pick a fight with Imam about that
because I've seen that happen uh on you
know I've worked in the media for 35
years I know how that game's played
um so so that would be my only comment
she's entitled to her view
um you're entitled to your view I'm
entitled to my view but I think it's I
actually think it's quite disgraceful to
label someone ignorant purely because
they don't agree with you it's not
acceptable to call someone ignorant but
you can call them disgraceful Imam
well no no I said doing it is
disgraceful the same thing you just call
it I'm saying Iman you're describe
we just heard you you just said she was
disgraceful let her answer she was
disgraceful okay Iman you're a disgrace
for calling Tricia ignorant I think I'm
awesome personally so I just want to
throw that out there secondly I never
called you uh ignorant because you
didn't agree with my opinion I called
you ignorant because you have a lack of
knowledge there's a clear difference and
it was never about a view it's about
just understanding facts and when we
talk about unconscious bias that's based
on feeling that is a fact Trisha so it's
not about me and you disagreeing as two
black women I'm going to call you
ignorant in spite of your color if you
have a lack of knowledge simple as that
oh thank you so much you're welcome well
Trisha come on you've got to answer the
charge it was basically your ignorance
as in lack of knowledge of the subject
you were talking about
if somebody decides that I'm ignorant
I'm not going to sit here and try to to
dissuade them otherwise they've quite
clearly made up their minds if Imam
wants to call me ignorant and thinks of
me and ignorant what have you yeah fine
go ahead because she did a lot of damage
that day you did a lot of damage and I
had to come along and fix it just like
Harry did a lot of damage and other
people had to come along and fix it me
Shola kyande we had to come along and
fix your dirty works you know what I
don't have time for people like you when
you come on national TV spewing garbage
and you're right I'll actually add to
your second point I don't want to argue
because I'm a bit more in fact I don't
believe black women should come onto TV
arguing so I'll just leave it at that I
called you ignorant because of your lack
of knowledge
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
well now I've been teasing this also she
of course was a big pop star back in the
80s I went to see her at Wembley Stadium
actually in the Holiday Tour and she was
fantastic but then that was about 40
years ago and neither of us have aged
particularly well I would argue I've
aged slightly better than Madonna but uh
in recent years is this autocue going to
move well I'm gonna have to make it up
as I go I don't mind uh she's oh she's
lost the plot let's take a look
in this room all bets are off Amy
Schumer oh truth or dare dare I want you
to show me with this spread how you lick
your husband's
I mean
yeah I can't take any more of it I'm
sorry you know watching someone in their
60s behaving like that we've got this
other little hit and miss yeah these are
some of the greatest hits
yeah one under the bed got the bottom
and so on
just general this has been basically
what she's been putting out now for
several years and I'm sorry it's just
there's got to be an end to this isn't
there
absolutely I can't
[Music]
oh my God
oh see you right there
gone to the dogs quite literally there
with the old dog boat all right I think
we spare the viewers anymore of this uh
but joining me now is Music Manager
Louis Walsh and podcastos Leia let me
talk to both of you uh first of all you
Louis Walsh you want to defend the
indefensible come on mate it's all over
isn't it for Madonna it's embarrassing
it's not all over Paris no way she's her
tour is going to sell out you just watch
they'll be adding extra dates in every
city this is the greatest hits tour I I
would go and see her absolutely she's
iconic she's one of our biggest pop
stars ever you just don't like her no no
it's not bad actually I don't even care
I don't need to like singers to enjoy
them at all in fact quite the opposite I
don't need to like any artist to enjoy
them but in her case I find her behavior
for a woman in her 60s just utterly
embarrassing I mean if that was my
mother or something you'd be like
cringing
appears you're doing exactly what she
wants you to do you're talking about her
she's controversial she's always in the
news she's her own best PR person and
listen this tour is going to be massive
whether you like it or not
well I don't doubt it'll be a success a
bit like Prince Harry's book I don't
doubt it'll be successful it's just
unbelievably distasteful let me bring it
back I'm right Hans I mean you're a
you're a young woman I mean is this how
you'd like to be in your 60s
absolutely no I think the whole thing is
really bizarre I don't know why we're
celebrating this she looks like she has
potentially a mental health problem I'm
not sure why she's unable to just get
old gracefully her face looks deformed
unfortunately and I don't know why we're
celebrating this we live in a time where
people talk about body positivity but
she's unable to just accept herself and
grow old gracefully the video was
incredibly crass and I think the whole
thing is part of a much wider again
political feminist statement to say
women can go on for years being
sexualized and doing whatever they want
and you know the society is going to
love them for and it's not true I don't
really understand why she's not spending
this time in you know her later years
she's mid 60s now with her kids with her
grandkids maybe teaching them everything
she's learned in the music business or
in life over the last time I totally
agree I mean Louie Louie I'm not being
funny but imagine being one of her kids
right to the sheer volume of
embarrassing stuff that your mother
posts on Instagram and whatever and you
just
for them that's your biggest school
loving to deal with that there's that's
her job she is the Queen of Pop she has
millions of followers all around the
world they're all going to buy our
tickets this is going to be one of the
biggest tours of the Year absolutely
yeah I know she's not in a great place
physically because the last time she was
touring I was in Miami I was in the Cub
outside and she canceled the gig because
she wasn't in a good place right but I
would go and see her again this is like
your greatest hits tour Paris
why can't she go and do the equivalent
of a pipe and slippers just go and you
know put on a lot of clothes and go and
sit in a rocking chair and just do the
old hits from a chair no no she could go
to Vegas and do it she's gone all around
the world this is going to be massive
appearance it's going to be
controversial but she's a great
performer she's a great singer you're
not a target audience let's be honest
both of you I believe I'm not a target
audience lay a final word to you I mean
will you go and watch this show
I definitely am not gonna go watch it I
see no difference between what she's
doing showing her body off to the entire
world in the most
um disgusting fashion to mothers on only
fans and how their kids feel in school
totally inappropriate um and I think
it's quite disgusting all grandmothers
on only fans I think we could raise them
exactly uh listen Louis I appreciate
your efforts to defending defensible but
I'm not buying it uh Leia thank you you
spoke Common Sense on the matter uh
unfortunately it will be a Smash Hit
This tour and people will go but then
people like to look at car crashes on a
Motorway uh good to talk to you Mo thank
you very much indeed
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
15 months ago Alec Baldwin shot dead a
female cinematographer on the set of
rust a movie he was starring in and
producing the death of Helena Hutchins
is one of the most appalling tragedies
in Hollywood history now there was no
doubt that it was an accident but Helena
Hutchins died leaving behind a
grease-stricken husband and a young
child and the person holding the gun
that fired a bullet that killed her was
ale Baldwin it was him that did that he
fired the bullet into his co-worker's
Bud body and snuffed out her life nobody
else's hands weren't even near the gun
but since that tragic day Baldwin's been
the epitome of Hollywood arrogance he's
embarked on a woeful self-pitying PR
tour that felt cynically designed to
make people feel he was just as much of
a victim as the woman he killed he's
repeatedly spewed indignant denial of
any responsibility to his millions of
followers on social media and in a
succession of Television interviews
here's what he told ABC News
do you feel guilt no no I feel that
there is I I feel that that that
someone is responsible for what happened
and I can't say who that is but I know
it's not me no guilt at all even though
he was literally holding the gun that
fired the bullet that killed this woman
not a shred of personal responsibility
accountability or guilt here he is
addressing his fans
I wanted to take a moment to
say thank you to all of the people who
sent me such kind words and uh
you know best wishes and strength and
hope and prayers and so forth and
thoughts and lots of encouragement and
lots of really really great
um
sentiments from so many people I got
hundreds hundreds of emails from friends
and family and colleagues and people
that I
and some I hadn't heard from in quite a
while to send me a
strength and good wishes and so forth
and I'm very grateful for that I want to
say thank you to everybody and online on
Instagram many people commenting
sorry
you haven't just won an Oscar
I saw that speed sounded like didn't it
an Oscar Redemption speech
no it's his real life it's not a film a
young woman was killed
well today Santa Fe prosecutors
announced that he Alec Baldwin and the
film's armorer a young woman called
Hannah Gutierrez read will be charged
with involuntary manslaughter both face
up to 18 months in jail if they're
convicted but Baldwin should a form
issued a statement through his attorney
striking a familiar tone
this decision distorts something that
hutchin's tragic death represents a
terrible miscarriage of Justice his
lawyers said Mr Baldwin had no reason to
believe there was a live bullet in the
gun or anywhere on the movie Set we will
fight these charges and we will win well
we'll see about that because that's not
what the prosecutor thinks here's what
the prosecutor said
we've talked to many actors
um A-list and otherwise that have said
that they always check their guns or
they have someone check it in front of
them so it's not an actor doesn't get a
free pass just because they're an actor
and that's what's so important is that
we're saying here in New Mexico
everyone's equal under the law everyone
has to follow their duties and do what's
right and take that safety into account
so that this doesn't ever happen again
well that's right that's what I hear
from actors too they all check if
they're firing a firearm in any capacity
on a movie set they all check just for
their own sake never mind anybody else's
there's no live ammunition or anything
wrong with this weapon that they're
using Alec Baldwin's done a lot of
talking a lot of self-protective talking
a lot of spinning a lot of denial of any
accountability or responsibility well
his next words on this matter will be in
a court of law
Julie you've covered a lot of court
cases uh self-evidently but what do you
make of this and how much Jeopardy is
Alec Baldwin now in
he is in big big trouble peers thank you
so much for having me on your show it's
a real honor and a pleasure to be with
you he is looking at a world of problems
with these charges this has been an
investigation that took so much time I
want to show you something Pierce I have
in my hand just a portion of the
investigation reported 551 Pages we know
they were investigating since October of
2021 when poor Helena Hutchins was
killed and this is just a fraction of
that investigative report so this has
been quite thorough a very weighty
decision made by these prosecutors in
Santa Fe New Mexico to not only announce
charges forthcoming against Alec Baldwin
but also against the armorer and prop
Master Hannah Gutierrez read I am
certainly not surprised at these charges
Pierce what is it to you when you've
been through all this what is it to you
that rings out which may be as if you
said by the prosecutor what is it that
brings out you think which points to
negligence by Alec Baldwin
you hit the nail on the head just now by
using that word peers the word
negligence that's what's so key because
I think what's hard for most people to
wrap their minds around when you hear
about this is we all know it was tragic
we know there's been nobody more upset
than Alec Baldwin and Hannah Gutierrez
read her attorney just issued a
statement a short time ago saying how
upset she's been since this happened
nobody wanted anyone to be killed so I
think what's hard to understand is that
in America you can face criminal charges
even if you don't have bad intent with
the charges that these two are going to
be facing There's No Malice involved
there's no evil mind or you know
depraved heart no this is just somebody
acting negligently without using do
caution and circumspection doing what a
reasonable person would not have done
under those circumstances so with
something that was accidental something
that's so unfortunate and so tragic
there can still be criminal liability
attached peers yeah and I think there
should be I I I have found Alec
Baldwin's PR tool sickening absolutely
sickening he should have shut his mouth
I'm waiting for the legal process to
come out instead we've had these endless
attempts to distance himself from any
responsibility whatsoever he feels no
guilt I would feel pretty guilty if I
pointed a gun at someone and killed them
even if it was an accident I'd feel
guilty I'd feel like wow I just killed
somebody but there's nothing not a shred
of that it's all been self-protective
it's all been about protecting the brand
of Alec Baldwin and I've watched it all
on Instagram with his wife doing the
same thing you know portraying him as a
a tormented family man going through
hell on their endless expensive holidays
and so on well fine I don't want to see
it I don't want to hear it I just want
to see the legal process play out and
find that exactly and I think we will do
now exactly how responsible Alec Baldwin
was not just as an actor who didn't
check his own gun before firing it at
somebody and pointing it in a woman's
head but also as a co-producer of a that
appeared to be a total safety shambles
and at the moment he's saying nothing to
do with me gov which I think is
completely unsustainable
uh judge I don't know about you I'm
absolutely raging about Alec Baldwin
generally at the best of times I just
felt that his his extraordinary
self-pitying tool to try and distance
himself from accountability on this it
may actually have backfired and led to
this D.A wanting to nail him
you know peers I just interviewed the
D.A on the case and I don't think
there's anything that motivated her
other than the evidence in this case but
as it relates to what you said in your
comment I agree with you the fact that
this guy Alec Baldwin thinks he's so
important that he's going to go out
there and tell the world that he didn't
do anything that he never pulled the
trigger would never point a gun at
anyone and pull the trigger that is and
you know I ran the DA's office I was the
D.A I mean for you know three decades uh
that that is what any D.A looks for in
terms of evidence it is an inconsistent
statement that the D.A made clear is
contradicted by the FBI forensic
evidence when you've got a Colt 45
single action you do not it does not go
off unless you put your finger on that
trigger right it is a single action
firearm and his arrogance and and you
know you'll see on the the five today my
interview of them and I think that the
most interesting answer that the D.A
gave me had to do with the fact when I
asked her you know did Baldwin cooperate
with you and uh she was very very
hesitant in her description and I
referenced there when she wanted his
phone when it first came out that he
directed his assistant to uh get rid of
the archives of messages so we've got a
guy who's arrogant he's condescending
but that's not the basis for the charge
the basis for the charge Piers is that
he took a weapon he pointed a weapon at
a human being and he pulled the trigger
and he did so to a mother in the prime
of her life and she lost her life now I
don't care if you're on a movie set or
on the Avenue of the Americas outside
where I am right now you do not do that
and the fact that he's charged only with
involuntary manslaughter he is
consistent with the law but there is an
upward sentencing there if they
determine and this is up to the jury
that the use of the gun was a part of it
so he faces up to six and a half years
wow I didn't know that uh and Santa Fe
you're going to get a jury that will be
familiar with guns many of them will own
guns themselves we'll have a view about
it yeah and they'll have a view about
gun safety generally what is clear from
this set was that the safety was a
shambles you had people already walking
off set in protest at the lack of safety
you've got a very young armorer who was
just 24 years old very inexperienced but
my question was Remains the most
perplexing thing what were they doing
with a hot gun anyway in terms of
potentially having one why would he have
to ask is it hot or cold how could that
even be a question and why would any
live ammunition be anywhere near a movie
set
and that's precisely the issue appears
and you understand that that any move a
movie set that has live ammo on the set
is is negligent as far as I'm concerned
per se but don't take my word for it the
truth is and I asked the D.A about this
in my interview the truth is that not
only was it an unsafe set there were the
there were two live rounds that went off
and this the armorer whose charges
Hannah guaterra's read I was 24 years
old who never should have applied for
the job because she herself admitted she
didn't have the experience but her
father was famous and therefore uh
Baldwin said you know I'll save money
here and the D.A was very clear the D.A
said money was more important than
safety on this set but when a live round
went off and she knew it and workers
were walking off the set they said it
was unsafe at that point you have to be
you have to be an idiot to not
understand
that you've got Guns live ammunition
live rounds going off and you're
pointing a gun and pulling a trigger
come on this is an idiot oh you have to
be an arrogant a Hollywood movie star
with a hot head which is what we know
Ali Baldwin is uh judge thank you so
much for taking the time I know you're
flat out today including on the five
you'll be thrilled to hear I'll be
joining you on the five in a month's
time again uh it's one of the joys of my
life working with you on that
occasionally and ours as well tears we
look forward to it take care Justin
thank you very much for taking my time I
appreciate it
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]